now police in norway are going to be
temporarily armed after a man armed with
a bow and arrow killed at least four
people ali fordescu has been following
the story and a news conference this
evening from norway uh what's the latest
ali
evening anna well just to bring you to
the beginning it was 6 30 this evening
that police were first called to reports
that a man with a bow and arrow were
attacking was attacking people in
kongsberg which is a town an hour or so
away from oslo in norway they have since
held a press conference in which they
say several people have lost their lives
and a number more have been injured they
say there is no active search for more
people one person they believe was
behind the attack but it is too early
they say to say what the motive was but
as you say crucially we now understand
that officers nationwide have been
ordered to carry firearms they have they
declined to comment on exactly how many
casualties there have been it is perhaps
worth saying some local media reporting
at least four people have died that is
not
confirmed but police have say several
people have
lost their lives no mention of terrorism
yet but clearly a very significant
attack this evening involving a man
over a large area of the town of
kongsberg in norway with a bow and arrow